against a backdrop of smashed up
buildings and war crimes this is what
the referendums look like in regions of
Ukraine occupied by Putin's men
it's no wonder it's been described as a
sham vote and an affront to
international law ballot boxes taken
around the houses and even into
hospitals where people were urged to
cast their votes on the issue of whether
to join Russia
foreign
in some towns according to Ukrainian
media residents did turn out to protest
this was
mikalayev region
and the surrounding villagers not to go
to the referendum and not to participate
in the illegal holding of the referendum
glory to Ukraine
but this fake election is a foregone
conclusion for the Kremlin it's the
first step towards annexation the areas
occupied by Russian forces will then
fall under its nuclear umbrella in a war
that is escalating fast Vladimir Putin
has clearly been rattled by the success
of Ukraine's counter-offensive it's why
these referendums are being held so
quickly but he also has another problem
closer to home ordinary Russians are
slowly becoming aware of the cost of
what their president is still calling a
special military operation
Mass conscription was never part of that
plan but as you can see it is now as
many as 300 000 are eligible for the
draft and judging by those called up to
enlist Youth and experience it seems are
not required
and as they say tearful goodbyes to
their loved ones what's happening in
Ukraine is becoming that much more real
of course I'm ready to protect the
motherland but not now not this time for
sure I think it's not my wall it's
probably the war of Russians and
ukrainians not mine
partial mobilization is something
Vladimir Putin had resisted it's not
popular and made back fire the Kremlin
is denying its policy is triggering a
mass Exodus but images at border
crossings with neighboring countries
tell their own story
men fleeing Putin's war of aggression
and heading for a safer place
Alex Rossi Sky News Moscow